so blumber capital is um has been around
for 32 years early stage VC started by
David blumberg who uh um is a is a great
Zionist uh investor as um he's from the
us so we are a us-based fund we have
offices in four different locations San
Francisco New York Miami of course now
you have to you got to have Miami's
office right in today's
atmosphere and of course T aiv which is
one of the main offices of the of the
fund we are investing in B2B software
companies and we are starting very very
early meaning we can do sometimes
pressed but we prefer CED and a rounds
um our first check is usually between
half a million dollar to5 million and we
continue to invest in these companies
for the for as long as they are
interesting and had the potential to
become uh at least a billion dollar
company welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret core Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
ctec
yis welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you so much for joining me today h from
obviously the blumberg Capital offices
thank you very much for being here how
are you thank you for inviting me it's a
great pleasure to meet you and uh let's
make this as interesting as
possible 100% so your F straight to the
point you're you're one of the um um
respected and well-known figures in the
Israeli
ecosystem um you've
been pioneering working with Incredible
companies for many many years um in in
executive positions and in investment
positions from software companies that
are very you know modern and are Cutting
Edge today either in the security scene
um in the in the marketing scene
sometimes but also companies more in the
infrastructure layer of society ER and
really that that touch on the daily
lives of of each of us and so you've
really seen the breadth of different
organizations and and the different
decision- making and so I'm particularly
curious to hear about about your journey
and and how you've shaped your interests
and what what you're excited about and
and I'm most of all then interested in
in piecing together with you what who
how you now decide who you want to work
with and what what matters for you now
that you've seen so many leaders and so
many entrepreneurs I'm sure that there's
different bits and pieces of intuition
and and decisions that you've come
together so so tell me a little bit
aboutum blumber Capital that you're part
of now and and then I want to trace back
to your journey yeah sure with pleasure
so you've said so many things that I
have something to say about uh and
especially uh you know the the very very
very diverse variety of things that I
was involved with and it has a purpose
it has it has a goal and it has a a lot
of meaning um um that I'll be happy to
share with you uh of course so blumber
capital is um has been around for 32
years early stage VC started by David
Bamberg who uh um is a is a great
sanist uh investor as um he's from the
us so we are a us-based fund we have
offices in four different locations San
Francisco New York Miami of course now
you have two you got to have Miami's
office right in today's uh atmosphere
and of course T Aviv which is one of the
main offices of the of the fund we are
investing in B2B software companies and
we are starting very very early meaning
we can do sometimes pred but we prefer
seed and a rounds um our first Jack is
usually between half a million dollar
to5 million and we continue to invest in
these companies for the for as long as
they are interesting and have the
potential to become at least a billion
dollar company for that we uh raised
five funds to date and also we have a
new opportunity Fund in order to allow
us to actually be there for the longer
term um we are 22
people um and across the different
offices with different expertise and
what we have which is I think quite
unique in our fund and this is part of
the work that we've been doing in the
last few years is that we have uh added
value Services some of the people that
you know very well for instance uh our
we have an HR Services where we help the
early entrepreneurs to build their HR
strategy that goes hand inand with the
business strategy so we brought for that
I think leading worldwide expert she
used to be sh M she used to be the head
of HR in A200 at the time that you
served in the unit and of course you
knows I remember the name very
well so of course she knows the system
and the ecosystem and the people and you
know bits and bites of who can work with
who um and she's part of the team a very
important part of the team we have
marketing business development we have U
uh PR and we have which is quite unique
a CIO Council we have 160 members from
the largest companies in the world like
Disney and GAP and Google and Amazon and
IBM and so I'm not doing here promotion
for anyone but just to emphasize the
importance that we see by connecting to
the industry and and creating Network
for entrepreneurs very early in their
life cycle in their Journey so we we
have uh meetings every quarter uh that
actually allows the entrepreneurs to
meet these people that that are usually
you know sea level in these companies
until you meet them it takes almost
forever and they have the interaction
the first interaction early on and then
they can continue to ask questions some
of them uh serve as Advisory board
members in the the companies and
sometimes they become customers
sometimes exit Partners so we are
thinking about you know always the next
phase to see how we can actually serve
best the the the entrepreneurs guys like
yourself um super talented coming from
different places in the world leading
universities and so
for incredible so take me back to your
own your own Journey so um obviously
you've been in in this space for for
quite some time I'm I'm going to be
interested to later understand the
transition into to blumberg and and um
you're obviously very intentional with
your your own decision making
how did you get into the world of
investing in general choosing to be on
that side of the
spectrum I think it's something that you
actually get from it's it's kind of a a
dream that you have from very early on
and usually and you know I'm sure that
you'll identify with that you get it
from
home um so uh I've been in this uh space
uh you know very early in my in my uh
you know youth days because of my father
he used to be in the banking industry he
used to work with you know very large
companies industrial companies but also
Hightech back then I'm I've been in the
industry for over 30 years so back then
there were not many tech companies in
Israel however the one that were uh
around were very famous and everybody
were looking at them and see taking
examples and taking uh looking at the
leaders of of these companies and and
and trying to actually do a copypaste of
what they're doing so back then there
was only one funding Israel it was
called
yma really really many years ago but as
I mentioned my father was in the banking
industry and I started my career after
the Army as a teller in in Israel
discount bank so I was actually a
cashier uh working there for um I think
almost a year um which was very very
weird but after that I uh traveled to
the Netherlands and I used to work for
Investment Banking and private banking
in Amsterdam which got me even closer to
the industry that I'm working in uh
today and in 1994 which is a long time
ago my father started business for
business development between Israeli
tech companies and Japanese company so
it started from Tech and expanded to
many other uh um areas and I did it for
10 years at the end I also managed the
company uh but it gave me such a an
important foundation to everything that
I'm doing today you know I I got to
learn about business uh tolerance and
patience and how to actually understand
that when somebody is saying it's very
difficult it means no and how to
actually intiate uh different cultures
and to help Israeli companies to
actually understand different culture
which you know it's not very easy and
it's not trivial at all especially in
the Far East so I did it for 10 years
and it was super interesting and in 99
in
2003 I was offered to join orbitech
which was one of the customers of our
and I was leading the VC of uh orbitech
super interesting role at the end of it
it was a CVC in a very small Market and
we recommended to actually close the The
Venture arm of the company and I got an
opportunity which was amazing uh to
actually start a new Division and uh
which was uh the um Medical Imaging so
my first interaction with the um the
healthcare world was via this uh this
company which was interesting after that
you know many opportunities came along
and I was um I was sitting as a board
member on behalf of ortech in in uh
industrial companies and also biotech
companies with and some of them went
public so you know a little bit bit by
bit you get uh information you get
experience you get you know to learn new
new things from different disciplines
which was very very interesting and and
I was curious all the time I was
learning and reading and you know not a
lot of internet back
then um after after that I was offered
by the sovich family to actually manage
their business in Israel and it was you
know a dream job so I did it also for 10
years and I was a chairperson of a real
estate company and I was a chairperson
of hotel management company and a lot of
private equity and we invested from the
submarine cable to pharmaceutical
companies to Industrial companies to
tech companies to storage company to
cyber companies so the the large variety
really uh it was a huge exposure to
different vertical but it was also an
amazing opportunity to learn about you
know different market segments different
Technologies um and it was a lot of work
you know when you invest in a company
you what what what did you start
learning about you know your own
interests or your own passions as your
because it sounds like you have so
you're you're quickly building on this
arsenal of so many you know you big you
know diverse and and um experiences that
really push you constantly to new limits
what are you starting to learn about
your own passions and your own interests
here yeah that's that's a great question
I think the bottom line is that it all
all about people you know and it's not a
cliche when you say you know people
matters and so forth
but the things that were my biggest
success um um that I'm most most proud
of is the interaction the relationship I
build with entrepreneurs and with
managers in and companies because it
brought deal flow Network friendship
which is very dear and very deep um and
I think this is this what makes me you
know super curious different verticals
different segments bring different
entrepreneurs but the bottom line is
that I'm always drawn to the same kind
of people you know people that are ERS
people that are super Innovative people
that are creative and people that can
work with other people super individuals
is something that is very hard for me to
actually understand and also help you
know part of my role as an investor is
to actually see what you need as an
entrepreneur and actually build an
infrastructure of services that will
serve you will suit you personally and
people that cannot interact and are
super genius and there are so many
people that I missed because of that but
you know the bottom line is that the the
main I think common de Dominator is that
I'm drawn to people that can actually
cooperate with other people that have
Vision that can actually see the team
grows and uh can lead other people to
the success that the
technology allows
incredible do you have a if you're
looking back at the companies you've
backed and the entrepreneurs you've
experienced are there instances that
come to mind that really exemplify you
know these key leadership moments where
you're looking at somebody and saying
okay wow this Behavior or this event
really you know put shines light on how
how I how you know I think entrepreneurs
can can really succeed yeah definitely
and I think you'll you'll you'll
understand it best because of the time
that we're living in um now and I think
that entrepreneurs shine best when there
are crisis okay when there are things
that need to be resolved that you need
to be super creative and human at the
same time with a lot of uh you
know understanding of what the other
people need what the market needs what
the customer actually needs crisis can
be from very different you know places
it could be in the product it can be um
in the market it could be with other
investors it could be with the founders
you know sometimes Founders you know
that establish a company do not get
along for the life you know after few
years so crisis comes in different
shapes and forms but the the true
leaders shine best in in times of Crisis
and these are the people that I will
invest in over and over and over and
over and over again even they fail the
first time but there's something about
the resilience there's something about
you know I'm there no matter what and
I'm not running away when things are a
little bit
tougher
um makes me uh you know I'm drawn to
this to these kind of uh entrepreneurs
and people and I think now you see you
see it all around us you know people
that can actually see three four steps
ahead these are the people people that
will actually succeed in the times that
we are in and will shine eventually and
their companies will succeed and their
team will stay with them for a longer
period of time
so and the other type is are the people
that can actually come and say that they
have a problem and that they are
transparent and working in a way that I
can actually um open all my network and
everything that I have in order to help
them and this is building the trust with
the entrepreneurs from day one I think
this is the most important thing um in
every relationship but in investor
founder relationship it's even you know
it's even bigger it's even more
important it's even you know we are
giving you guys um not just money but
the reputation the network the uh
opening doors we trust you we trust what
you say we trust the product that you
build we trust the team that you uh uh
recruit we trust the next phase we trust
that you're doing the best that you can
and and we need you to trust us as well
at the same time so transparency and
trust these are things that you know I
will I
will I will uh take the moon stars and
then son for uh for entrepreneurs that
are transparent and trustworthy
wow no I I I I can I can definitely feel
that coming from you and looking a
little bit ahead you know we're just at
the beginning of
2024 it's a crazy world that we're
living in we're we're in the middle of a
crazy time in our own
ecosystem um which speaks to a lot of
the resilience and the crisis management
and the leadership that is being
exemplified here you know looking into
the next one or two years now from an
Investor's hat you've seen a lot of
different markets a lot of different
Industries what are you particularly
excited about
now um you mean in Market uh segments or
twinners and companies but well both
both if you're thinking about where
you're going to be spending your time
over the next two years what types of
people what types of
markets I think there there are several
things that are happening around us on a
macro level that we have to uh to
actually you know stop for a second and
build a new strategy as investors okay
we've been seeing in
2022 and
2023 um a tech Global crisis uh we
thought it would be bigger than it is
but actually affected a lot of investors
the interest rate where we in the in the
financial sector has been high in order
and and it created some kind of uh you
know um disadvantage for us as a
long-term investors where uh investor
decided where to put their money so we I
think it created a situation where we
all need to be even more professional
even more creative even more open-minded
that we were before so the the macro
level really influenced a lot uh the way
that we think and the way that we Act
and the way that we invest the second
thing is is that
technology huge uh leap that we've been
seeing in the last year where Ai and and
Chet GTP became you know kind of uh must
have
technology um so the data element is is
playing a a much bigger role in our
decision making processes with regards
to new Investments the financial sector
uh the Enterprise sector requires a lot
of efficiency processes so the CFO Suite
is super interesting for us um it it has
data in it it has AI element it has you
know large important uh um um
Enterprises are interested to um make
their you know companies more efficient
more relevant more transparent by the
way uh to the sea level that they
working with these are the things that I
think will be very interesting on the
other hand there is a lot of new
regulation coming from the um clean tech
Market um coming from the fut Tech
Market coming from uh cyber world so we
were not that strong in fut Tech and
clinch so far we have not invested in
this this market and and now we are
starting to look at clinch on from the
financial side okay not uh not from the
science side it needs to have a very
very very
um specific uh Financial uh use case or
um um that we can actually um understand
and see the
long-term um the long-term value for our
investors of course Cloud infrastructure
is always interesting but it quite quite
crowded I would say and uh during covid
we invested in seven very very
interesting uh digital Health companies
so I think in the next two years we will
try to do our very best to help them
actually to penetrate the market
increase their market share and and be
exposed to more and more and more uh
customers around the world um
so I think you know the the the theme of
most of our funds is data now it's data
in AI so whoever has interesting
software B2B company in the spaces that
I've just uh mentioned it it could be
super interesting in the other thing
that we are concentrating in is Supply
Chain management which is not very
strong in Israel but super strong us and
we have several compan companies in this
space they are going through A
disruption really really big disruption
uh uh of uh you know technology moving
to the next level of data in AI also
very relevant to what we're doing
now I you f I think that you know
hearing you talk about your own
excitement and predictions for the next
few years it just shines back to what
you were talking throughout the first 20
minutes about you know your your own
your own interest in in leadership and
the entrepreneurs that you want to be
backing and working with but also your
experience and working with many
different segments and many different
markets and it's clear that you have um
that you have insights and you have um
you know respect for for different
markets that are that are rising and
you're you're looking at them and I
think that's also probably what makes
this also very a very exciting time to
to invest and to be a part of this
ecosystem and I really want to thank you
for the time here thank you for the
inspiration and for sharing your own
Journey with me I really appreciate it
I'm excited to share this with other
young entrepreneurs and friends and
colleagues and uh thank you for
everything you're
doing thank you and I think the most
important message and thank you for your
what you're doing I think it's a very
important although it's very very short
is that the doors are open we are all
looking for the entire industry looking
for interesting entrepreneurs and
blumber capital is doing its best to
actually help them to grow and to become
great success like our other you know 10
different unicorns so thank you for
having me wow and incredible may we have
great
2024 amen
amen
oh